there was a fantastic article that I
read years ago by Eric Davis and it was
about what he calls the art of
experience design the first thing he did
was say that the evanescent flux of
sensation and perception that is all we
have and all we are is a prime material
for mediation right Stephen Johnson
famously said our thoughts shape our
spaces but then our spaces return the
favour' so we're dealing with the
technical material of subjectivity
itself and having a kind of authorship
having a kind of agency over your own
experience as it unfolds in time William
James famously said your experience is
what you attend to Terence Mckenna
famously said you become what you behold
and I love this idea people talk about
getting in flow when they are in novel
environments there's this idea that the
greatest experiences are those in which
we can lose ourselves in and enter an
altered state of consciousness something
akin to a liminal trance right the
immersive trance and my interest in
patterning patterning and programming
these unspooling zuv experience has to
do again with a thirst with a desire for
agency and authorship over my
experiences write famously someone said
I design therefore I become my creative
and linguistic choices govern my fate so
the metaphor that I was using before in
conversation with my friend Jason
Goodman is treat your life like a movie
treat the greatest experiences of your
life like a movie like the moments that
would make final cuts right my final cut
I mean the moments that count so what do
you do you exercise discernment and you
exercise desire for stewardship of ant
turn a life by treating these
experiences like movies so you're in the
editing room and the movie is unfolding
you're creating and perceiving your
world and you have a metacognitive
awareness of what's unfolding and so
you've preset an environment for a
particular experience to unspool so what
I'm talking about is if you think of
array of the world that you construct
like a movie I'm talking about pre pre
designing the spaces in which that movie
will unfold in the same way that before
a film reel unspools the story that is
gonna be patterning your experience is
already scripted edged into the
celluloid and so what I'm saying I'm
saying like pre designing contexts in
which experiences that are like movies
that are essentially waking dreams that
are immersive trances that are liminal
trance States limb annoyed experiences
can unspool can unfold in this pre
patterned environment so it's it's
taking a lot of the principles that in
VR they they speak of when they talk
about presence it's taking a lot of
principles from narratology
and immersive theater to essentially
choreograph and stage design
environments that again love this
metaphor will unspool as you unfold so
that it's like wow man this place is so
magical I'm having an epiphany I'm
having an aha moment this is so mystical
well because we've pre-designed you know
we pre decided to come here we came to a
mythic landscape that we could easily
that appropriate into our buzzing
unfolding waking trance date our flow
you know so it's like it's like stage
design in your life stage designing your
theater before you hit play on the play
you know even if you're improvising
you've created a canvas for the
improvisation to unfold knowing that the
canvas will feed back into the
experience and that is wild right even
the words you use to map reality will
affect your experience of reality
context isn't just something you
describe context informs war
do not just describe words are
generative landscapes are generative
they cue the unspooling of a particular
type of experience because we are
feedback loops we are made through our
creative and linguistic choices and what
I'm essentially promoting is the idea of
exercising control you must take control
of your life life exists in individual
moments and it is up to us to make sure
that those moments are vital
interconnected and grant to make a
masterpiece out of our lives one that we
would willingly live again and again for
all of eternity
this is what we can strive for make of
your life a work of art make of your
life a portal to the transcendent
and remember play just play